j'ai jamais voulu cette ville arts pour
toi
je voulais quelque chose de totalement
différent
une belle qui tombent tous les mois des
enfants
femmes et
pas un moyen de sortir d'ici au 15
rapide
[Musique]
on veut vous transféré dans une autre
prison afin de pousser un détenu à vous
livrer ses aveux
[Musique]
on suspecte cet homme d'avoir tué 14
femmes mais nous n'avons trouvé qu'un
seul corps
l'arrivée des rêves qui sont très
spéciaux par et moi 2 dans mes rêves
j'adore tuer des femmes mais ce ne sont
des ré
cette prison où il est détenu c'est une
prison qui est spécialisé dans les
criminels à l'aîné
[Musique]
me demander d'aller faire un tour en
enfer et de faire copain copain avec un
monstre non pas question même pour tout
l'or du monde et pour la liberté
hall a fait appel de sa condamnation
il pourrait gagner et être libéré vous
avez la chance de l'arrêter
ne vous approchez pas lui trop vite
sinon il comprendra
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça c'est
comme si tu me connaissait
si jamais on découvre
lundi du risque de passer un très
mauvais moment
accélérer le mouvement
s'il sort il tuera à nouveau
encore et encore
si tu penses que tu es en danger
c'est que tu es en danger